this was a hard question this was a hard
question and um if you if you did poorly
in it
you can forgive yourself because number
one is towards the end so you know your
hand was kind of like ah by now and uh
it really was it took a lot of thought
this question okay and it's quite unlike
all the other questions so that's why
i'm going to spend some time on it
it gives you a um an expert system
basically okay and you have to answer a
bunch of questions about it so let's
review
the table below shows a partially
developed knowledge base to be included
in an expert system so that's why you've
got all of these rules and that kind of
thing the logic is there okay that's
what a knowledge base is
this system is used to determine whether
a security license should be issued to
an applicant and is used during
interviews between a clerk and an
applicant so they sit down and this is
what they go through these the steps
they go through to try and determine
should i give a license to this guy or
not
okay so let's start construct an
equivalent decision tree for the logic
in this system okay now this is actually
a super super easy decision tree to do
because when you think about um
uh what rules you've got here okay
and the actions that result
there's only a single action really um
well actually an action and it's and a
lack of that action that are the final
ends of the decision tree what's the
what's the main action you would think
you get it yeah that's right um so
security license issued is action number
one the only other thing that can happen
right action number two which is really
not an action at all
is to yeah that's right to reject the
applicant to not issue a license okay so
at the end there were just two actions
right
so if we come over here here are my
rules so
i'm going to have actions
over here not to be confused with
decisions by the way okay because some
people head of this as decisions and
they had a whole bunch of things under
here which related to each of the rules
that were in the table okay but there
are only two actions
issue
issue license
right or
don't issue license
okay so being that these are our two end
points right what are the ways that
you've got to go through well all the
way over on the left here you've got a
whole bunch of conditions that you need
to meet yes so over here
conditions
now i can tell because of wow that's so
messy sorry guys i can tell because of
how how big my writing is i'm not going
to be able to fit all the conditions
here but basically we were looking for
all of these
right i'm looking for what where do you
start you start for correct age okay so
the first thing you should have is a
branch that says morning
um
correct sorry actually should be huge
age right and it's going to be greater
than or equal to
18 i think right so
um if it's yes then you continue up to
the possibility of an issued license and
if it's no
right you automatically
are hit here right you don't need to
answer any more questions okay
does that make sense and the same thing
happens for the next step
what are the conditions that starts to
look at good references right so then
you say yeah this should be good
references
good
references
okay if the answer is yes
it continues right and and you might
have to meet more conditions in order to
get to here if it's low you
automatically come down to here right
and it's the same kind of pattern now
you can see i'm going to run out of
sorry this should be a yes here and it's
the next condition here
i've got around space but you're getting
the idea right what's the next thing
good reference is australian resident
right so then they say
is it an australian
resident
okay and if the answer is yes then you
keep going and if the answer is no
then
off you go okay so you get the idea now
there's only two marks the the marks
really were for number one do you
understand what a decision tree is like
do you understand the format of there's
conditions and there's actions and it's
a yes no kind of thing okay
the other mark was for did you get all
the right conditions uh i i've run out
of space to put them all okay but you
simply had to
finish off going through them step by
step and there was no complexity to it
there was no weird branch or anything
like that okay
so that's why i was just it was just two
months
now coming to the next question
we now wish to modify the rules above to
include information
relating to sorry relating to the
completion of mandatory training okay so
at the moment uh this has nothing to do
with training so you could have someone
totally unqualified walk in and if they
leave in the right place and they're old
enough and and so on okay some people
people think highly of them then they
can get a job that's great okay
or maybe not so great so
they say we want to
incorporate mandatory training as a
requirement
and these are the specific things you
they want about the training
it must be offered by an organization
which is an rto okay so not just anyone
that rto has to be approved by a police
commissioner and they have a master
license number okay so that's fine
and then after that
they have to not just do a course but
they have to do well in the course yeah
so their result must be 100
in this section on more greater than 50
overall in all the other sections okay
by the way just for what it's worth this
first condition here is what we call a
barrier condition um not that you need
to know what it's called but sometimes
in university you'll sit
um you'll go through courses and
there'll be one section where you've got
to get everything right
and if you don't get that right it's
over it doesn't matter how well you do
and all the rest of it
if any of you have any of you're going
to get your ells yet you're not licensed
you've got yours so you know how you did
the 50 question do you still have to do
the 50 question quiz
40. a lot of questions right and it's
multi-choice if you've never seen it
before right
you actually go online and there's a
whole bunch of practice questions
they're not really practice questions
they're the actual questions you'll get
asked um yeah well it's it's it's good
it's because if you've done like a few
of them it gives you a random set each
time but after you do it like four or
five times you've done all the questions
so you get anyway um the questions on
alcohol blood alcohol limits right
they're one of these they're a barrier
question right so it doesn't matter if
if it's 40 questions if you get 39 out
of 40 correct and you get this one wrong
it's over you don't get your l's okay so
anyway though it's very easy now i think
it's like the limit for l's and p's is
zero so anyway it's not even 0.05
sorry i digress
uh we now have to modify these rules
modify any relevant rules in the
knowledge base and include any new rules
to incorporate this extra information
okay all right now how many rules are
there at the moment there are seven okay
so it seems logical to say
i need some new rules that have to do
with this so we might start with rule
eight okay
so let's move down a little bit
okay now let's have a look at the
structure of a rule okay um it's got a
rule that's about like okay is it is it
this kind of you know is this true or
not right and the way you know it's true
is you have a look at these conditions
okay so let's have a think about this
um you might say something like okay
is this person have they received the
relevant training yeah they said well
okay how would you know if they've
received the relevant training or not
and you can have a look at all of these
different bits here okay so there are
conditions in here so you might call it
what they call this um authorized
training
okay so that's the name of my rule right
i'm going to say yes this person has
received authorized training if and now
i have to make a statement about okay
have they have they received it or not
right
so i think they've only actually
received the training once they do you
remember um
once they've done well in it right
they've got a good score okay so i'm
going to incorporate these two bits here
okay now because they both have to be
true at the same time
and right simultaneously i'm going to
say
um if score's a hundred percent in law
okay and then here's my uh my
my boolean logic keyword okay and come
in
scores i think it was greater than or
equal to 50 right yeah greater than or
equal to 50
in
other
sections
okay
does that make sense right
um now not just to have to do well but
they have to do well in a specific kind
of course offered by a specific group of
people right so i'm going to have one
more condition on the end of here right
to say yes you've got authorized
training which is that it's from what
are they called they had a name
a registered training organization okay
so i have to say
um and offered by an rto
okay and now
this is why i chose to end on this now
you can see where this is leading well
how do you know it's an rto or not and
so you have a new rule
so that was eight so this is going to be
nine okay so how can i tell whether it
was a registered training organization
or not
okay well they gave me some conditions
didn't they
if uh what was it let's see
approved by the police conditioner
number one and
has a master license number number two
okay it's gonna have both so we say
if approved by a commissioner
the police commissioner
and
has
master
license number
okay
so when you look at that okay uh can we
quite see it all yeah there you go all
right when you look at all of that you
can see that that accounts for
everything in these two dot points okay
it's all there you can read through it
again and um we haven't missed any of
these little
important conditions
there's one thing missing okay which is
that
in what how would how would the
knowledge base know to start looking at
rules eight and nine
because when you have a look at the
existing rules right for instance why
does um
why does number six rule six why does it
get looked at why does the knowledge
base look at it and the answer is
in rule five it talks about authorized
referees right so the knowledge base
then says well okay how do i know it's
authorized so then a new rule kicks in
does that make sense okay but right now
none of these rules currently refer to
rules eight and nine right they're just
kind of sitting off on the end and
they're like an island like they're kind
of like the tasmania of this knowledge
base okay no no connection at least not
yet
so i need to come back to the question
i need to modify some of the rules in
the knowledge base so that rules eight
and nine get um get activated does that
make sense okay
so
my question to you is which rule do you
think we should change which one do you
think we should add something to
conditions there yeah i think i think
number two is the way to go for um some
people went for rule number one and that
was kind of an okay response i think i
paid it but
it's a condition isn't it that they've
been trained sufficiently right so i
think it makes sense to put it under
rule two to say under here and
what did i call this i think i called it
authorized training
ta-da okay so now what's going to happen
is it's going to go through each of
these in turn and eventually you'll get
to rule 8 unknown okay
right so